نعم حسن حقيقه كان يوما قاسيا بالامس على
مدينه خانيونس تحديدا جنوب قطاع غزه هذا
اليوم شهد سلسله من الغارات الجويه والقصف
المدفع الذي طال مناطق عده في المنطقه
الغربيه وربما كان الابرز هو استهداف مقر
تدريب وكاله الغوث الدوليه الامر الذي ادى
الى ارتقاء عشرات الفلسطينيين واصابه
العشرات ايضا كانوا محاصرين لعده ساعات
حتى تمكنت طواقم الاسعاف من اجلاء نحو خ
40 اصابه نقلت الى مشفى الشهيد ابو يوسف
النجار في مدينه رفح وصبت اصابه 15 منهم
بانها خطيره بحسب وزاره الصحه الفلسطينيه
هناك حاله من الخوف والذعر مع استمرار
حصار هذا المبنى الذي كان يضم عشرات الاف
النازحين الذين اتوا من مختلف مناطق قطع
غزه ونزح الى هذا المبنى منذ بدء الحرب
على القطاع هناك ايضا محاولات اسرائيليه
لتطويق مخيم خان يونس من المحور الجنوبي
والغربي والشمالي الغربي بعشرات المركبات
العسكريه الاستراليه والدبابات والجرافات
ال ايضا الكبيره التي تحاول تحت غطاء ناري
بري وجوي الدخول الى قلب المخيم وسط
اشتباكات عنيفه وضام اقتربت هذه
الاشتباكات ايضا من محيط مبنى مجمع ناصر
الطبي غربي خان يونس وايضا هناك قصفا
مدفعيا متواصل على محيط مدارس الاواء التي
تاوي عشرات الاف النازحين بالقرب من هذا
المجمع ايضا مجمع ناصر الطبي استقبل نحو
40 شهيدا منذ ساعات الصباح الباكر جلهم
كانوا جراء القصف المدفعي وايضا الغارات
الجويه على المناطق الغربيه لخان يونس
ومنطقه حي الامل تحديدا ومنطقه المخيم
الغربي هناك ايضا عشرات من الشهداء
والمصابين لم تتمكن فرق الاسعاف من الوصول
اليهم حتى هذه اللحظه بفعل منع تحرك
مركبات الاسعاف من داخل مقر الهلال الاحمر
الفلسطيني الذي بات في مرمى نيران القوات
الاسرائيليه سواء القصف المدفعي او حتى
الطلق قات الناريه من الدبابات والطائرات
المصيره وهذا الامر ايض ايضا الى سقوط
ثلاثه من الشهداء صباح هذا اليوم والى
جانب ذلك سته من المصابين امام هذا المقر
الذي تعرض لنحو خمس او ست مرات لقصف
مدفعيا للطوابق العلويه في مقابل ذلك هناك
حركه نزوح كبيره وواسعه النطاق كانت في
المنطقه الغربيه لخان يونس بفعل اطلاق
النار والقصف المدفعي المتواصل والطريق
الذي يسلكه هؤلاء النازحين هو الطريق وعر
وخطر جدا ويمتد في المناطق الشماليه حتى
مرورا بالطريق الساحلي الغربي والتوجه
جنوبا اما الى رفح واما شمالا الى مدينه
دير البلح وسط قطع غزه ايضا كان هناك
اليوم نسفا للعدد للعديد من المربعات
السكنيه من قبل القوات الاسرائيليه في عمق
مدينه خان يونس جنوب قطاع غزه بالتزامن مع
ذلك كانت هناك اشتباكات ضاريا وقصف مدفعيا
في المنطقه الشماليه الشرقيه والشرقيه
الجنوبيه لخان يونس بالقرب من منطقه
الفخاري في مقابل ذلك المقاومه وبالتحديد
صرايا القدس وكتاب المجاهدين وكتاب القسام
وكتاب شهداء الاقصى وابو علي مصطفى في
بيانات منفصله قالت بانها نفذت عده عمليات
قنص واستهداف لعدد من الاليات العسكريه
صاليه وايضا استهداف قوات متحصنه في عدد
من البنيات السكنيه في المنطقه الغربيه
لخان يونس تحديدا وهي المحور الاسخن في
هذه المرحله وايقاع عدد من القتلى والجرحى
في صفوف في هذه القوات في مقابل ذلك ايضا
كانت هناك غارات على مدينه رفح جنوبي قطاع
غزه طالت مسجدا في المنطقه الشرقيه وادى
ذلك الى سقوط خمسه من الشهداء ونحو 10 من
المصابين وصلوا مشفى الشهيد ابو يوسف
النجار في مدينه رفح في المنطقه الوسطى من
قطاع غزه هناك اشتباكات شرقي مخيم المغازي
وتواصل القوات الاسرائيليه ايضا هدم عشرات
البنايات السكنيه في هذه المنطقه عبر
تفخيخها مسبقا ومن ثم التفجير في ايضا
مخيم النصيرات كانت هناك غاره ادت الى
تدمير عدد من المنازل السكنيه وسقط على
الاقل اربعه من الشهداء في هذه الغاره الى
جانب غارات كانت في منطقه الزهراء ومدينه
غزه وجباليا شمالي القطاع هاني الشاعر
مراسل الجزيره حدثنا من رفع شكرا جزيلا لك